hello I would like to thank first for
having me here and also in particular
I'd like to thank Daniel and Paul too
for notching the organizers to accept me
I wasn't original plan to come here so
that's a really great honor to be able
to talk to you today what I would like
to present is it's a library I've been
working on for quite a while which is
called Q and Q allows you to create
cross-platform GUI programs in pure go
so instead of having for example much as
your back-end code written and go and
it's perhaps some of your so-called
lower-level code written and go and then
on top of that you have written your
user interface your graphical user
interface in and say the Java libraries
or in react or something else that you
have to then connect with your go
program you can with you just write
everything and go so I've been working
on something like that for quite a while
in the sense that I haven't worked on Q
for more than one and a half almost two
years but I've been working for quite a
while to bring go into user interfaces
which i think is a very very
underutilized under you underutilized
area of use and go
so go is used everywhere on the back end
but very very little on the so-called
front and I know it's used for web
applications but for really
old-fashioned apps and and desktop
programs it's not very widespread so I
began to push for it in 2013 where I
wanted to just have anything running on
the Android phone and in 2014 como bol
appeared which allowed you to connect
your existing go code with something
that you had already written in in
another language so you can have an
Android application or an iPhone
application and have some of that
written and go and I tried to push that
a little bit further with that my Girl
Talk which tried to be through access
the Java or Objective C or Swift
libraries directly as you would do in C
Co if you know C Co you can import
uppercase C and then you can x-axis C
functions and types and so on from go
directly and that's
try to do with the reverse bindings well
it did work but the problem is that you
if you've ever used anything like go
mobile or seco in in particular you
probably seen that it quite quickly
introduces problems where you have one
side of the world which is written in C
or Java or something else and then you
have your go world and each and every
time you have to cross that language
barrier you run in not in problems but
as your program grows you have more and
more references across this barrier and
that leads to complexity is like
reference cycles where you can have
references across that a cycle of
references across that barrier which
will not be garbage collected
even though ago is no garbage collected
language and so on so I decided in I
think it was early 2007 17 to say let's
go away from go mobile
the mcgraw mobile style way of writing
apps and let's try to write everything
and go so that means the drawing the
input handling the window managing and
everything and that's what that's what
the Gil library tries to accomplish it's
still very very new because it I only
released it in March so it's not there
yet but it does what I think a lot of
interesting things and a part of that is
that it can actually create a program
that is that is useful enough for you to
use so what I have for you today is the
program called scatter and scatter is a
program for end-to-end encrypted
messaging except instead of using your
phone numbers I'll just show it here
instead of using so it looks pretty much
like any other chat program but it's
written in in pure CO and it runs on the
cue library and instead of using your
phone numbers as identifiers and some
proprietary service for message
transport and simply uses your existing
SMTP and IMAP server for sending
messages back and forth but the
interesting part about scatter is that
it's as I said pure go it's written with
no native code
in the scatter project yourself
everything is handled by the glue
library and still it functions as what
you would say a good old fashioned
desktop app on Mac OS so let's try this
is this is the scatter three account
using the scatter three account and
scatter one happens to be connected to
the iPhone simulator so let's say hello
so the iPhone simulator and I'll send it
it's a bit small I know this is the text
a bit small but it looks like a chat
chat app and you have the chat history
here and you have your context here so
let's take the simulator up and start
the scatter app and you can see the
messages up here in the bottom it's it's
a little bit difficult to see but I can
tell you that it did up here and of
course you can ride it back and say
hello back you can tell from the history
that I've done this quite a lot of times
hello back from iPhone like this and it
should appear up here and while we wait
for that we also have the Android
emulator that was hello back from iPhone
so we have the Android and emulator here
where we can again write a message to
the Mac OS hello Mac OS from Android so
whoops so this is actually a functioning
program it's a preview it doesn't have
that many features but it does have the
does have scrolling it does have the
Edit fields it does support the soft
keyboard and so on so it does a lot of
interesting things and it's actually so
that's so functional that it is that I
feel released it in the App Store so
even Apple accepted this app on at least
on the test flight build so if you go to
the website for this program you will
actually be able to download it on your
phone with if you have an Android on on
iPhone now
what are the features of queue today I
think the most important one is that
it's written in something that is called
immediate boat design I will get back to
that in a moment but in the background
it's written so it's very very portable
through only using very very little from
the platform so instead of using all the
platforms native widgets say the iPhone
text editor and the label and the
buttons and so on
it simply depends on somewhere to draw
on and access to your graphics card so
that you can display hardware
accelerated graphics and of course it
also depends on some way to get user
input in the form of clicks and mouse
moves and keyboard input one consequence
of being in an immediate mode design
it's is that it has to be very efficient
I'll tell you in a moment why but so the
consequent is that you have to be
careful about creating too much garbage
so some of the design choices has
actually been done with with with this
constraint in mind so most if not all of
the drawing and layout code in this
library is designed so it will not
generate any garbage so you won't have
any troubles from the garbage collector
and at least not from Gil your program
could still generate too much garbage
and because it has so few dependencies
it already runs on all the three major
platforms desktop platforms as well as
the mobile platforms and it actually has
the ability to be built as a weapon
bleah and web at WebGL program so that
it can run directly from the browser all
of this from the same codebase yeah this
is the scatter
homepage and and links to the app store
bills so now I would like to attempt to
show you the design choices of you that
makes it in at least in my eyes very
simple to write GUI programs even from
the scratch from scratch from the ground
up so let's start with a very very
simple mango and we'll just have the
package main and we'll have a func main
this is the program that you're used to
seeing mean this is program that you're
used to seeing starting with your
writing a let's say command-line tool or
web server or anything like this and the
first thing that you have to do to write
your program is that you have to give up
your main goal routine and that's a
that's a car that's a unfortunate
consequence of the way that UI libraries
work the native UI libraries and window
management system works on some platform
so I don't think there's anything we can
do about that
that also introduces you
the only packaged packaged app which is
the only package that actually deals
with the low-level platform all the
other packages are written in pure go so
we're giving up the main control main go
routine to the system so we have to do
all the fun stuff in a go routine whoops
like this and the first thing you would
like to do is create a new window and to
actually have responsive window you have
to run its event loop which means that
you have to accept all the events that
come in the channel of system events and
system and Vince are events like resizes
and keyboard input and so on so let's
just range through the event queue like
this and see what happens and this is
just running with go run it go runs this
file that I'm editing and as you can see
it returns the result is a functional a
blank yet functional window with just
that those few lines which behave like
you would accept any expect any other
application to behave now to actually
draw something
interesting in here you have to tell you
what you would like to have displayed on
your display in your window and the the
way you do that is to react to the most
important event type in India which is
the update event so let's just switch on
the type of of the event let's pull out
the event here and switch on the time
and say if we if we receive an update
event then we'd like to draw something
or at least update the window stage and
drawing and update the window is done
through Windows Update method and let's
just end that here but to tell update
what you want to have display it in an
immediate mode design you can't just
take if you're used to some other
widgets widget toolkits and in other
languages you might be used to having an
implicit tree and hierarchy of widgets
so say you have your window on top and
then you have containers as children
through that window and below those
containers you have widgets and so on so
it should actually have something drawn
you have to put in buttons and and
labels and text editors and so on with
an immediate mode design you simply
specify from the time on from the time
to start - from the beginning to the end
the entire content of content of the
view and the way you do that in India is
to specify the drawing and input and so
on through operations and one operations
I would like to the most simple one for
demonstration is the paint operation
just to be concrete it describes an area
where you want to have drawn the current
material and the current material could
be a color it could be an image at least
for now further down the road it could
be a gradient something something like
that so a paint operation takes a
rectangle a floating-point rectangle
where you have to specify let's just say
the max so just have the size of it
let's say it's 500 times 600 pixels like
this and then of course just specifying
the operation is not enough you also
have to add it through the operations
buffer that we that we're defining in a
moment I'll just import like this so so
this down here is an operations buffer
that that the paint operation will
serialize itself in term and we'll just
define it in the beginning and this
operation buffer is also what you gave
to Windows Update like this so and it's
just import the package so let's see it
running yes
so this is a very boring rectangle but
the but the concept still stands you
define operations and you add them to an
operations buffer which we have over
here and you give that entire buffer to
window start update and it will replace
whatever was present there with the
updated operations buffer and that's
that's the that's the style and idea by
an immediate mode to sign you don't have
any state hidden in the library you have
every state controlled and owned by your
application and that becomes important
as your program grows and you want to
update it in a way that fits your
application and not in a way that fits
the user interface library so let's do
something a little more interesting to
lead this operation let's draw on some
text and to draw some text you have to
have a font loaded and some other
support things so I made the package
symbol which makes it simple here on
stage that can symbol but that can
create labels and and other widgets for
you so let's import it the Gopher cons
simple package
and that theme you can then use to
create a label let's say hello world
just to keep it safe and then you also
have to specify font size let's say it's
a 46 and to draw this one you have to
give it the operations buffer because it
has to put its drawing somewhere and you
also have to specify the constraints of
this widget and we just call it
constraints here I'll get back to what
constraints this in principle
constraints are in a moment but for now
let's just create rigid constraints
given through the size of this one
so again create a theme which could be
the material theme in our case is just a
very simple theme that that makes very
simple widgets and you create this
widget which is stateless so you just
create it on the fly as you draw and
saying I would like to draw hello world
and we'll draw on this size and you
asked that to draw itself to the
operations buffer which is then passed
through the window that update of course
I forgot something you have to reuse the
to be garbage free you have to reset the
operations buffer to reuse is from
update to update right okay we'll have
to extract science and here and
right whoops okay one more thing the
theme also know that has to know the the
configuration of your window so it has
to know what's the what's the resolution
of your window so that when you draw a
label it will have the same size across
all types of screens so it has to know
it in the recent method the
configuration and you're getting this
congregation figuration with all the
information through the config object on
the sizing event like this so after all
this work we have the hello world thank
you very much
and one thing I'd like to point out with
this Helliwell is that the label is
actually able to do line wrapping and
that gets back to where we have the
concentrate constraints defined for it
so the constraints are giving are
specified according to the size of this
window which we have up here these
constraints so the constraints tells the
label what are the available sizes for
you
so constraints contains in the width and
the height dimensions contains what's
the minimal and maximum sizes in that in
those start and those dimensions that
you can take our space so as the
constraints get smaller then the label
is forced to do two line wrap now let's
say you'd only you want to draw to the
labels let's say you draw two labels
here we have the number two whoops
number s number two number one and you
just do that
of course the labels will appear on top
of each other and the job of placing
which it's relatively to each other and
relative to the edges of your container
or your window is handled by the layout
system and in view that layer system is
inspired by flutter if any of you has
used flutter before it's actually the
constraints is the same thing as in
flutter where you have constraints that
you give to widgets and as a result of
laying out itself the witches will give
back your to you the actual dimensions
that it shows so in this example we
actually can get the dimensions back
from the first label just to show you
how you wouldn't manual the layout and
then we can use that to extract the
height of the first label and I know
that it's going to be converted to a
float by using taking the size from the
dimensions in the y-direction and then
we can take that and offset with another
operation called transform operation
where you can offset it with a floating
point point in the y-direction height
pixels
I think that's okay and then of course
you have to add it to the operations
buffer no you didn't like this whoops
it's gone okay not one more thing one
more thing this constraints tells by
saying rigid constraints it tells that
the minimum and maximum size is the same
and you have to fill the entire screen
so the first label actually takes up the
entire space so we'll loosen their
constraints a little bit by saying the
minimum height can be serum so the first
label here is allowed to be as tall as
it needs to be let's try again and there
you go two labels and you can see even
though the first label resizes itself
and changes height the other one will
follow so that's the basics of the
layout operation of course doing that as
you can tell from from this demo is
tedious and error-prone so instead of
using manual offsetting and so on you
will use layout various layered helpers
which are available in the cue library
and one of those helpers is alignment so
let's try and use that the way you use
alignment is you initialize it with a
direction which which can either be one
of the compass directions or simply
saying in this case that we'd like to
sender it like this and you give it the
original constraints and you get back
from an alignment operations and
modified set of constraints that you
give to that widget that you'd like to
be centered to have senders so that's
what pops up over here and finally you
need to end it by giving the alignment
operator or helper the dimensions of the
widget so it knows how much to offset it
to actually Center it whoops and let's
see if that actually works it does first
try
now they're also more complicated for
example the more complicated layout help
us available let's say you want to have
multiple widgets aligned with each other
and place them on a row for example and
for this example let's use just regular
rectangular rectangles colored
rectangles so one thing you can do is if
you have a rectangle and you have a
color let's say green and you want just
want to lay it out it will if everything
works correctly oops
take out the entire screen space like
this so say you have many widgets which
is this is one widget and you have many
widgets that we want to place on a row
he will use the Flex layout the VEX flex
layout is similar to the align layout
and that you have to initialize it and
you have to tell now I want to add a
child another framework you might add a
charge of this flex here you just say
specify that I want a child of this flex
layout and in this case we will just
make it fill up to take up half the
space of the screen so like this half
the space of the screen and then of
course you need the dimensions again
from your widget and end by calling and
dims and finally you are rich you
returned an object that you then used to
layout all these children you will just
start with one of them to see that it
actually works
like this taking up half the screen and
say you want to add another one we'll
just copy this say we'll add another one
with the color blue
and this case we'll just give it half of
the remaining space which is a quarter
of the total space like this so as you
can see laying out widgets and declaring
which and just drawing something on the
screen it's very very immediate in an
immediate mode design you don't add it
to a tree you don't have a hierarchy of
containers you don't have any state
hidden in your library you just create
what you want to have created and drawn
and tell it to draw and that's actually
how you structure larger programs except
that when you reach for widgets that
actually have the state which needs to
be retained across updates instead of
have these two static rectangles or a
statics list of labels you might have
something that react to user input and
one such example is the list and the
list is a widget that can layout other
widgets like the Flex layout that you
saw here but instead of having all of
them laid out you have perhaps a
potentially very very large list and you
only want to show some of them and you
want the user to be able to scroll
through what part of this large list
that you want to have visible so let's
get back to the to the label like this
and let's create a list so because this
list has state you have to have a handle
you have to retain it somewhere but it's
there again this is this is the job for
your application the the gila bridge
does not decide how or where you want to
draw this reference so we have a layout
list and give it an axis in this case we
want to have it vertically and to use it
you simply initialize it you give it the
configuration give it the input Q where
the events come in the operations for
storing its operations and of course the
constraints that it has to contain
itself into inside and this Q is where
all the events appear from the Q system
through your program and to the widgets
that need those
events and the default queue is simply
the one that is supplied by the window
and with all that set up you can simply
run through this list and only have to
display and work on those that are those
child elements that are actually visible
so you say as long as the list has more
elements to show we'd like to have the
next one
and inside this for loop is simply where
you draw this child element in this case
we just draw an a label so let's make it
a little bit more interesting by saying
the label must be dependent on the index
off the list so we'll just say okay
this is the index and the index is is
returned from the index method from the
list and you also have to use the the
constraints that the lists stress
specifies you for the child element so
that is contained in the constraints
method and with that and finally you
tell the list that the child took up
this much space and I think that's it
not enough arguments - oh yeah you
actually have to tell it how large how
what is the size of your packing list
let's say you have thousands or ten
thousands of elements
like this no like this okay there you go
so you have ten thousands of elements
but only the ones that are actually
shown are being processed and drawn so
you can have millions or tens of
millions of elements and still have the
same efficiency so that's how you draw a
list in immediate mode right I don't
know how many of you have tried to make
lists in other languages but there's
usually something with an adapter
involved and you have to get a callback
and so on so this is a very explicit way
of doing it you're using the go control
structures in this case just a for loop
to go through the visible elements and
then simply draw that element and that's
it
so now let's say that you want to handle
events yourself in this case the list
takes events from the queue and handles
that it detects scroll wheels it detects
flings on the phones and so on but let's
say you you want to react to input
events yourself so let's try to add a
button a simple icon button and let's
have that button drawn on top of
everything else that's the beginning
it'll come up there did everyone see
that
I think I was too quick it will appear
up here let's just leave it there for a
moment and let's say you want to react
two clicks to this and the usual way at
least with the frameworks I've been
using you will have to register a
callback somewhere to get back click
events for this widget with an immediate
mode library you asked for the events
that you where you need them so you ask
where are what are the available events
at the point where you want your
application wants to process them and in
this case let's say this button adds
more rows to the list so let's say the
list the number of rows in this list is
specified by the variable n and let's
start with a low number and at this
point just before drawing the actual
list you would like to handle events and
not some other time when the callback
decides to call you back and the way you
do that is
you forth through the available events
saying with the name in this case e as
and as long as there are more events
from the button as returned by the next
method given the input q you would like
to continue pulling out events from this
button reason that that I duplicate
these two next calls is that otherwise
you have to use of three lines to exit
out of the for loop but the style is up
to you and in this case I know that the
events that we get back from this button
is of the type gesture click event so
you have to check if this is actually a
click or just a press so we'd say if
this events type is a click will simply
increase the number of rows
like yes so you can see but reacts to a
user input it can actually animate
itself by asking the system to redraw
itself and for each event that you
receive you add another label and just
for posterity let's as a final thing
layout the button in the southeast
corner
like this and like this dimensions there
you go so this is if you squint a little
you can actually see the beginnings of
an app that looks a bit like scatter and
that's actually how i bowl II built up
this chat application that you saw
earlier so let's say we have this
finished app and we would like to not
only run it on the desktop but we'd also
like to run it on the mobile phones and
that's luckily for you it's also
provided it's very difficult to do with
eyes at least in my opinion to do with
Android studio and Xcode so what I
wanted to do is again do it everything
from go and then have a very simple
command like the go tool where you just
go bill Corr install and go run for
example this program we can just run
with go run this package and you will
have this application I would like to
have something similar for the mobile
platforms so there's a tool included
with you which is called queue where you
can call it by giving it a target in
this case let's just use Android which
will then build your program for Android
and packages package it into an apk
which is the format that an Android
phone or similar simulator will accept
you can then use the in the standard a
debate @b tool to install this APK like
this and if we're very lucky it will
appear in the program list like here
again we have the three rows and we can
but Android is easy in this respect
because as you all know if you've ever
done anything with iPhone it's very very
difficult to get anything to work in
that and that on that platform it's very
difficult to get on the App Store so
well the queue tool comes to your rescue
target iOS and then again this directory
and because Apple is May has made their
system so that the simulator is subtly
different from the device you have to
decide you have to give the cue tool you
have to specify to the give to whether
you want to build for a simulator or
whether you want to build for a device
or the App Store and you give and you
say that by specifying the output to be
either an IPA if you like to have it
installed on your device or an app
directory if you would want to want it
to run in a simulator and then there's a
tool included with Xcode where you can
install to the Buddhist simulator this
live app
so it appeared here again three rows and
you can just add more and you can scroll
it and you can do everything you want
the reason that it's it's squished up on
the side is that the mobile devices will
specify an inset where you have to move
all your drawing to be inside but you
also want to be drawn drawing outside
this if you have a scrolling list so
that's why GU allows you to draw all the
way to the edges so that's fixed and
that is that is handled in the scatter
app but it's not handled by this very
simple app and finally the Thank You
tool supports building for the browser
in the sense that it will build weather
sampling module as and it will add the
required support files to actually serve
that module and run it in your browser
so let's try that that's the final thing
chocolate Jas again this one this
package and it will output a directory
with the the web assembly module as well
as the HTML file and JavaScript file for
running it and I have a very simple web
server running that just takes one
directory which is the one that you want
to serve to the browser there you go and
with that you can just start localhost
connect to localhost 8080 and you have
your program running in the browser
again it's the same code built for is a
five four or four or five platforms
right now and you can have the button
working as you would expect and you can
also if we had rows enough you can
scroll inside the browser so I think
that is about it if you're not convinced
at this point
I would just I would like to reiterate
what the features of QR so the immediate
mode design is the most important thing
aspect for me so the other things
writing and go being portable is very
very important but in the in programming
user interfaces and apps in general I
think the frustration of using some
other frameworks is simply not there in
the same level if you can just draw and
state what you want to have drawn and
displayed on the screen so I think the
immediate mode design is a big thing for
me but if you just want to have
something to run that you can write and
go and it's portable across all
platforms then bu is there for you and
of course even on lower end devices
mobile phones and and devices with very
very weak CPUs every all drawing is done
with the graphics card so you shouldn't
be too worried about your program
drawing too slowly to keep up with user
interface and finally if you do if you
think that this is interesting for the
portability but perhaps not for the
immediate mode design and so on all the
source code is is is published on the
unlicensed myth which means that you can
simply take whatever you want without
any attribution whatsoever so use
whatever you like all of it I prefer of
course but if you just need for example
the air package for drawing a window
everywhere then you can do that so thank
you very much for listening and go to qu
i.org if you want to see more about the
Q library itself or go to scatter I am
if you just want to run or hath your
beta version installed on your phone I
will just have one little warning it
will ask you for your login details to
use SMTP and IMAP server because it uses
that for sending and receiving messages
please don't give it your main account
because I can't guarantee that it won't
mess something up so use something that
you're where you don't care about the
emails inside it okay so thank you very
much